yeah the jury has told the judge they
can't reach a verdict on any of the
three counts that uh ryan giggs was uh
was facing they've been deliberating for
for more than 20 hours since they went
out to to begin considering their
verdicts last tuesday uh they've been
called back into court uh they've been
told they cannot reach a verdict on any
of those counts and therefore the jury
has been discharged and we wait to hear
what happens next uh in this story they
heard 10 days worth of evidence evidence
that told a story of very turbulent uh
relationship between ryan giggs and kate
greville his his ex-girlfriend laying
there a lot about their private lives uh
during the course of that uh that
evidence but the central question was
whether ryan giggs was a violent
domestic abuser um he faced three
charges the first charge that he engaged
in in coercive and controlling behavior
over cape gravel for a three-year period
she described during the trial the
living hell that she'd been
going through described what she said
that she'd become a slave to his every
need and demand she said and talked
about a number of violent incidents
during the course of that uh that
three-year period um saying she was she
was caused to fear on on numerous uh
occasions the second charge was one of
um assault causing actual bodily harm
that referring to an incident at the the
home the couple shared back in november
of 2020 when ryan giggs was alleged to
have head-butted kate greville uh during
a struggle on the night that she was she
was due to end their relationship and a
third charge also out of that incident
that he'd elbowed her sister during the
course of that
scuffle but as i say um the jury unable
to reach a verdict
after some 20 hours of deliberation on
any of those charges
ryan giggs had denied them all along he
said that uh he'd never uh use violence
against a woman in any relationship uh
he said that they were it was the story
of routine ups and downs in in their
relationship
he admitted it was at times immature uh
pretty unpleasant some of the language
they used to each other but said he uh
he'd never been violent and said that
incident the alleged headbutt was was
the result of a uh of a clash of heads
but the jury heard a lot about his his
character and private life during the
course of this trial uh they were told
that was irrelevant to the central issue
the allegation of this controlling and
coercive behavior the allegation of two
assaults
and the jury which was reduced to 11
members actually one one juror became
ill uh last week uh but they've told the
judge in the last few minutes they can't
reach a verdict and we wait to hear uh
what will happen next as to whether
there's any effort to to retry this case
in the coming months